hey everybody
um this isn't gonna be a fancy explainer
video in fact
there's no animation in this video and
in fact you can look down at the time
code it's a really short video
and i'm just gonna tell you something
and explain something and then be done
but i have a lot of really cool videos
coming so
let me just explain hold on
and i'm at the ocean
[Music]
okay i just finished working on
a giant project
one of the things i said when i
announced that borders was
cancelled is that i would keep doing
this work
i would keep finding ways to do intense
hard-hitting journalism and i'm excited
to tell you that i
quickly jumped on an opportunity at the
new york times
and that opportunity turned into a
really cool video
and that really cool big ambitious video
that i've been working on for several
months now
is done and it's published and
you should go watch it uh because it is
uh something to put a lot of work into
so um the video is about
the us response to cobia 19. i got to
work with one of my
journalism heroes nicholas kristoff who
for many years i've read
and listened to and now i get to work
with him which was a really amazing
opportunity
and i learned a lot i learned a lot as i
do with every big project i do
was able to report on lots of different
aspects of this topic
so that video is live right now and
uh the link for where you can watch it
is
in the description and you should go
watch it so
uh that's all that is everything i've
got today um
i have a lot of stuff coming out really
soon
um i'm doing an explainer on a
an island off the coast of maine that
is really cool and weird i want to
especially thank the
flood of patrons who have come in
recently
uh to support this channel it just like
makes me feel so excited to keep making
stuff
um and a lot of videos are in
development now and should be coming out
um in october so
good to see you all even though i didn't
see you i'm just looking at a camera
while i'm actually looking at the ocean
and the camera and it's really bright
and i'm about to go eat breakfast
you